vous diriez vous grandir et l'état à
admettre que vous avez merdé pas à
limite pas vous personnellement mais que
ça a merdé que pendant qu'il y avait ici
qui avait rien qui se produisait et que
c'était la catastrophe et qu'on vous
tout le monde pouvait voir que ça allait
dans le mur et que il y avait des
signaux qui étaient envoyés avec ses
arrières et on n'a pas eu de réponse
donc ça c'est la première charge je
pense que vous vous rendriez vis-à-vis
des salariés vis-à-vis du territoire
vis-à-vis de moi comme le représentant
vous me diriez à dire ouais il ya eu un
délai pendant lequel on pouvait agir au
moins tirer le frein et on l'a pas fait
je pense que vous grandir y est à dire
ça c'est c'est la première chose
la deuxième seule chose c'est que moi je
souhaiterais sortir d'ici avec un
interlocuteur à l'elysée c'est à dire si
on doit suivre le dossier
je veux pouvoir dire que on n'envoie pas
un courrier à l'elysée il n'y a pas de
réponse et vous dites en bas on n'a rien
reçu mais après j'ai envoyé puis j'ai
envoyé non moi je peux faire à peu près
d'accord si jamais si jamais on veut
avancer sur le dossier d'objets si
jamais on va garder aussi avancé par
exemple sur les dossiers de l'increvable
l'histoire la machine adaptée sera
obsolescence pourra mais moi je demande
à voir un interlocuteur à l'elysée j'ai
de très bonnes relations avec madame la
préfète
je vous bien j'ai eu à contacter le
ministère du rail conquête industriel
qui s'est pas traduit parfois que ce
soit derrière mais c'est pas grave
j'oublie mais moi je veux un contact à
l'elysée pour qu'on puisse pas dire
monsieur macro n'est pas au courant
parce que voilà monsieur macron les
syndicats les ont alertés
moi je les alerter d octobre dès
l'automne de l'année dernière le 4
octobre
deux remarques étaient encore voir le
passé non non non non non mais des
français que l'analyse elle et elle est
beaucoup plus subtil que ça
je suis ok la pathétique
on sait que je suis passionné gros -
c'est pas grave on l'a bien c'est pour
l'avenir monsieur mâcon s'est passé pour
que vous puissiez pas dire bon c'est
beaucoup moins connu que les ouvriers
les salariés ne pense pas monsieur
macron il est passé est derrière les
propos qu'il a tenus on va pas pouvoir
les suivre mais moi je vous demande donc
un contact ils permettent clairière de
pouvoir avancer sur le dossier
travailler en liaison avec l'elysée
françois je suis si transparente qu'elle
vous n'arrivez pas trouvé non non mais
madame la ministre madame la ministre
sur ce dossier de l'increvable j'ai eu
un contact c'est monsieur floris il me
semble ils ont bien ri c'est parti oui
bon d'accord mais en tout cas voilà donc
on m'a donné un contact de quelqu'un qui
n'y est plus et maintenant du coup je
tombe je suis désolé mais sur le dossier
de la crau vab
je n'ai pas eu de nouvelles du ministère
j'ai envoyé une demande le les personnes
de l'ain combats font envoyer une
demande il n'y a pas de retour
voilà c'est tout c'est pas grave moi je
demande juste que y ait un suivi pas
seulement avec le ministère mais qu'on
puisse dire le président la république
voilà les jeunes mais parce que pourquoi
pourquoi sur ce dossier là parce que sur
ce seul celle là c'est vous qui êtes
venus en personne le 3 octobre 2017
vous étiez là avant vous êtes venus ici
donc il ya un engagement qu un
engagement présidentiel qui est
l'engagement de personnel
voilà pourquoi en l'occurrence est la
seconde marque phare à partir de là on a
fait non c'est pas vrai c'est fini non
mais non c'est pas la preuve soit pas
bref d'après ce que je sais je suis la
mauvaise loi j'ai voté
j'ai géré le dossier n'a qu on va boire
ministère à bercy et je n'ai enquête en
réunion madame la préfète et c'est moi
je la vois qui opine
oui je l'évoquais à deux reprises dans
des comités oui oui je l'évoquais je
l'évoquais je l'évoquais une fois bercy
je l'évoqué en présence de monsieur
fleuriste je l'évoqué à ce moment là
c'est ça les regarde les lettres elles
se perdent quand on intervient au
ministère du budget
attendez gauche ouais mais cool
maintenant on vient mettre en cause ma
bonne foi on peut le faire on peut dire
que chaque rond point je suis un gros
mois si on veux tu faire en revanche